um somebody um sent me a game that was
actually a toen horse and then he had a
chat in the game and says I can open the
the CD of your computer and he's like
open the CD and I was like whoa what
what what the hell is going on? I
thought it like supernatural almost
right and start to play with stuff in my
computer while he was speaking with me
over the chat.
[Music]
Royale, welcome to 20 minute leaders.
Thank you so much for being here. Thank
you for having me, Michael. Ry, I've
been waiting for this episode for a very
long time. Salt security is such an
awesome company uh in a world that I
love. I've been uh playing with
APIs since I'm 15,
14. And uh and you know, I I led I led
hackathons as a teen. I had a company
where we hosted hackathons around the
world and it was all about APIs, rapid
API was founded in one of my hackathons
and and so the this concept
of SAS to SAS software to software
communication is is awesome and and ever
since I went into the world of cyber
security and I got to experience a
little bit about the thread vector of
APIs, I was really thinking about okay,
how is this going to manifest itself and
here you are. So I'm really excited to
talk about yourself and API security. Uh
thank you so much. Yeah, definitely we
we can start whatever you want. I'll
just start with a disclaimer that's
saying that I'm having a call in the
last few days. So for all the listeners,
I apologize for uh for the voice and I
might mute myself here or there to cough
but besides that we are good to speak
about APIs security and everything in
between.
Absolutely. uh and uh well you know
you're a CEO and entrepreneur so I think
that at this stage you're you're used to
performing at your best everywhere. Um
taking me back to to your enlistment in
the IDF is is this where you you delved
into cyber security?
So uh so going even a little bit uh
further um I started coding somewhere
when I was 9 years old. Uh my mom signed
me up for uh like a coding programming
class because she saw that naturally I'm
being attracted to computer. I'm
intuitively like really good at it. Uh
already when I was first, second, third
grade, I did some web development when I
was 9 years old and I I really loved it.
And um 2 years later when I was 11
um I started to do some freelance work
uh off forums and you know people needed
as an 11-year-old does naturally. Yeah.
Yeah. you know, like uh not like complex
stuff. Uh but I started to get more and
more into it. And then uh I always had
this entrepreneurial um you know,
whatever you want to call it. Uh in
Hebrew, there's something that may
sounds negative in English, but uh like
something inside me that really wanted
to build stuff. So I built different
websites when I was 10 years old, 11
years old, 12 years old, like different
like you know stuff that uh basically
tried to monetize different website
building stuff. And then this is where I
got into a little bit cyber. I was not
an expert by no means, but um somebody
um sent me a game that was actually a
tool horse and then he had a chat in the
game and says I can open the the CD of
your computer and he's like open the CD
and I was like whoa what what what the
hell is going on? I thought it's like
supernatural almost right and start to
play with stuff in my computer while he
was speaking with me over the chat. So
uh this is where I were like fascinated
by what the hell is going on, how you
send me something. I play like a dumb
game and like a very simple game and
then get controlled. So I got more and
more into cyber before the army not an
expert level you know but start to
understand the concept how it works what
is told how computer works and so on so
forth. Then I went to the IDF I joined
one of the elite security units of the
IDF and I was responsible there for
building uh cyber security product or
systems uh from the ground up. So we
build the hardware, the firmware, the
software to protect every layer of of
communication. So layer one, physical
layer, how do you prevent like
electromagnetic uh leak or field like
field leak in layer two and layer three
and then all the way to layer 7. And
this is where I saw you know layer 7
application APIs. I saw that we are
really behind like we're using very uh
traditional methods. uh there's nothing
sophisticated like if you look at layer
1, layer two like electromagnetic field
like a lot of sophistication but layer 7
I thought wow that's pretty ancient uh
approach um and then I saw uh and this
is where I really gained my security
expertise you know this is where I
understood that everything I knew was
like a drop in the bucket and started to
expand through every domain of cyber you
know from like the what you can do how
you can hack uh hardware how you can
hack firmware how you can hack software
in so many different ways. Um, and after
the army, shortly after the army, I uh
Docker uh uh came out was very very new
uh the container uh
technology and Kubernetes went out in an
alpha version. Nobody talked about it.
It was not known. Nobody used it. It was
very very like it was just after that I
started to wrap my head on, hey, I want
to build something. I saw this
technology and I thought to myself,
"Wow, that that's interesting because
that means that if it's going to work,
it's going to basically take every
company, every application and break it
to tons of APIs because every monolith
application will be kind of turned apart
to
microservices." And this is where I
really kind of sparked the idea of okay,
APIs,
security, something big here is
changing, new needs, let's start to
explore it.
Yeah. And so you're leaving the army,
you see the Docker uh technology, you
you're expand into the microservices
framework and how this is going to
change the narrative and the strategy
for how different organizations deploy
software. When you're looking at it
though from from a cyber security angle
and you're thinking, okay, so I can see
the different threats that are that that
could take place and just to make sure
that we're aligned with everybody that's
that's also here with us, what how do
you expl explain those threats to me? So
what what could different groups and
people do considering this new
communication strategy that's being
deployed? Yeah. So so I'll explain
through an analogy I think would be
easier to understand. So before
pre-docer pre- kubernetes like in the
early 2000
um you can think about a company as a
building and the doors and windows are
APIs. companies mostly had monolithic
application that change every six months
of the year, right? We were not in a
days of agile development and of
CI/CD. So, it was mostly like think
about like a small house, townhouse, you
know, one door, couple of windows. We
put a a guard at the front door and it
was pretty easy to manage. Kubernetes
and Docker really turn turned this house
into a building and then a neighborhood
of building that changing every week
every day new window uh new door open
being open uh so I thought to myself the
first need is to understand what you
have you need to discover it was very
easy to discover when you have only one
you know one house you know your house
you know the doors and windows once you
start to have a neighborhood of
buildings it's very very hard so really
to map um uh all the windows indoors.
That's kind of the discovery part. So I
I realized that you know you can't
protect what you don't know. That's kind
of step call, right? Call walk on.
That's the call part. The walk part uh
it's what we call governance. Okay.
Let's make sure the windows are locked
at night, right? Let's make sure that uh
there is no sensitive data uh can be
carried out. So no sensitive things in
the house can be carried out by someone
and so on so forth. So uh let's make
sure that it's built correctly, right?
the lock is the right lock you know it's
like an easy lock to to hack and that's
the governance part. So making sure that
what developers are building is actually
built in a secured way uh uh before it
go to production to to real world
application and also whatever is already
built uh it's built uh correctly in
securely that's kind of the second
challenge and if you think about it
before I go to the third challenge if
you think about jai and lms it really
kind of it's the second compelling event
that really made this space much uh uh
much uh worse essentially from security
perspective. Kubernetes was the first uh
part right you have a lot of APIs
changing
rapidly. Now you can generate an API not
in days or weeks in minutes. So that the
the frequency of APIs being built and
change with geni and the chap cloud you
know you name it is just incredible. Uh
so and they're not even controlling
what's being coded exactly or really
noticing. So you can have a lot of bad
security because something generated a
code and you can implement it right away
with even with very bad security. So it
kind of made it even worse and the need
for governance and knowing what you
built if it actually comply with your
security standards really critical. The
last part is uh the run part is the
threat protection. I realized that
majority of the threats that were
prevalent in the early 2000 mid 2000
were not a common threats anymore that
uh lead to actual breach in the in the
real world. And I realized that with
APIs, you have a lot of manipulation of
the business logic of the API. You know,
for example, if I'm a bank and I have my
mobile app to uh to, you know, to to do
everything like to send money to to
receive checks or whatever it is, it's
very easy today. You will not even
believe how easy it is to manipulate an
API to get information of your bank
account uh or to even do actions on your
behalf. But um just to give you a stat,
we are dealing mostly with enterprises,
Fortune 500, global 2000 companies and
probably in every second organization
that we do some type of an evaluation
within 3 days we see a critical
vulnerability. When I say critical, it's
not on paper. It means if this
vulnerability was or would have been
exploited by a bad actor, it probably
would have cost the company tens of
millions of dollars like you know
leaking all their databases do things
behalf on all their
users. Uh we even had a study that shows
how we can get from crypto exchanges we
can pull all the money out like tens of
millions of dollars like worse but like
the worst of the worst. Um APIs are very
weak from a security perspective by
design because the people that create
them are not incentivizing are
incentivized by building security.
They're incentivized by innovate fast,
develop fast, which is kind of many
times contradicting with security. So
right, discover, govern, and then
protect whoever try to break your your
door coming in. you want to keep them
away from your from your building aka
the the company
and you know S salt is not a new company
you've you've actually founded it I
believe almost almost a decade ago right
I mean nine years ago uh so not exactly
true um uh like I I had the idea about
in 2016 so close to it like late 16
actually about 8 years ago um but I
realized there's while there was a lot
of validation to the actual uh uh thread
vector and need. It was not an
established category. There was no so
the first actually uh what I did first
is I uh uh we went and we did Y
combinator and I was lucky to be
mentored by Sam Alman that today is the
CEO of OpenAI which was an amazing
mentor. Um so so I felt lucky but I said
maybe that experience getting getting
mentored by Sam Alman at Y Combinator.
Uh definitely that was amazing. Was uh
an amazing guy. It was in in you know in
retrospect I thought to myself three
years four years later I wonder uh how
would it would be I would have
experienced it knowing everything I know
now and if I would had the same level of
appreciation to Sam because I always
thought was he's amazing but I thought
maybe it's because I'm you know in the
first six months of being an
entrepreneur. Um I can tell you for sure
as you can see it was truly like
objectively amazing because you see what
an amazing company he's uh he's building
right now OpenAI. Um but in the first
two years we raised a little bit of
money but we didn't do our official seed
round. It was just cyber security angels
like the co-founder of checkpoint the
co-founder of Luca like different like
great like a safety like different
individuals great individuals that
invested in the company. um only two
years later when we felt the market
starting to be established this is when
we did our official seed round so we
officially did our seed round with a VC
in September 2018 so it's after like
more six years ago uh where we went from
five people and and then we really
started to expand until then we just
patent technology core technology like
the big data the ML like the big uh the
the key part but building companies
started two and a half years later. Why
was it so important for you to wait and
validate and reach a level of maturity
of validation before going to and and
before raising the seed round obviously
you know you're leaving the you know
you're white combinator elite army unit
big vision you know emerging market
yeah it's um I realized very quickly and
with Michael my co-founder that that
just for context Michael came was part
of the founding team at Adalam um who
know who's today you know the
co-founders of whiz uh he was their VP
of global sales and marketing so he sold
to their first second third customer all
the way to the acquisition to
Microsoft so we were very mature and I
remember he he told me back then is um
look we are very early we need to
educate uh because people are not ready
to buy like sophisticated people
understand the need but we cannot build
a company based on just sophisticated
buyers
and it will be very hard. So we need to
do the groundwork if you want to go for
it of talking to gardener established a
category went to OASP created the OASP
API top 10 like I didn't imagine it
would be I I thought like 6 months right
it took more time once we felt okay we
are ready to get like to raise money
this is where we we went and do it we
didn't want to raise money and then burn
it and then not be able to get to the
next milestone to raise our CSA and
Uh so we were a bit more careful. Um um
so we started to like we small money
enough to operate technology uh validate
it have design partners which we did but
we felt like okay we're being great
value to our design partners that want
to pay for it. So when we raised our
seed we had already three paying
customers. Um uh so uh we wanted uh this
type of validation before we actually go
big money and commit for a long-term uh
plan.
Wow. Phenomenal. If you had to go back
to toe of when you you were just
starting out Y Combinator. So now I
guess that's eight years ago. So even
before the validation what what advice
you know are you now taking with you now
is already a I'm calling you a seasoned
entrepreneur how how would what advice
would you give to yourself to younger
entrepreneurs? Wow. Um so today the
answer to me is very clear. People ask
me this question over the years and
every time I would give like slightly
different answer based on the spirit of
the same year. uh today after you know
almost $300 million in funding growing
the company selling to hundreds of
customers there's only one answer in my
opinion it's people it's all about the
people don't compromise on talent
especially your executive team your VP
of R&D the VP of product the VP of
marketing like early on every person you
bring needs to be excellent uh needs to
share the same values as you share needs
to think very similarly to you what is
speed what is moving fast the can do
attitude um don't compromise on less
than excellent in the you know I think
along the years uh we had again amazing
people but sometimes they're not a good
fit in certain stages or certain people
you bring in uh and this is where you
build a culture and I think that's the
foundation to everything you want to do
uh later it doesn't matter like it will
help you with the product with the
marketing like every aspect of the
company the core layer is the people so
to me like like There's
two main factors in success of a
company. One, if you chose the right
market and then the people you have in
your company. If those two are correct,
everything probably will in a way it
will be very hard. It need to do a lot
of smart decision but it will work
itself out because you have a group of
very smart individuals that working hard
that share the same values. So people
people don't run like just be focused on
yourselves and like oh yeah we hired
three engineers. no like no damn
interview. Get familiar with your team
and making sure you always have
excellent team. So that's that's my
advice. I love it.
And if I so if I walk into your offices
when you're 10 people, so it's the
original people, you're building the
culture, the sophisticated buyers are
there, but the market is still maturing.
What what do I feel? What's the culture
at Salt Security at 10 people?
Um I think uh one and by the way today
we codified it um to to five things
which I think really started early on. I
think it's uh we worked as one team. Um
um people were like I always brought
every sales engineer when we had the
first 10 people we had the first sales
engineer. I brought them to Israel the
first two weeks of their job because I
want to make sure that everybody work as
one team. It's not sales and product and
R&D. It's like everybody is one team. So
they feel very comfortable talking to
each other, call each other. So very
collaborative. Um we worked and and
still working very hard. Um smart but
also hard because being like an elite
cyber security unit uh company is very
hard. We know it. Uh so you need kind of
to outwork, outbeat, outsmart your
competitors. Uh I think very customer
obsessed. So very in listening mode to
the customer and not saying oh they they
don't know it like they are you know bad
buyers they don't get it like go to the
next one. Every customer I looked at
this in a and everyone in the company is
an opportunity to learn why I didn't get
it. Maybe our messaging is not good
maybe the product maybe it's not
intuitive enough. always take it as no
ego and really understand what's like be
very open
um and can do attitude like we can do
everything like the customer need like I
remember in the fourth customer he said
oh I need this capability it's really
key and we're competing you know like we
had two days later like the POV app I
was like let's build it let's build it
today and like in two days it was very
simple version of it but we got it done
so like we we heard your your feedback
and we built it like what do you mean
you built it. We said it two days ago.
He's like, "Yeah, we we're moving fast."
He was so impressed by it that he said
what one of the reason why we went to
Salt is we're so impressed about how
much you took something in and you
brought it to life in 2 days. Wow. Um so
that's like the spirit of things in the
in the early days and even today as
well. Obviously when you go it's not
exactly the same when you have a large
base of customers, but it's definitely
like the spirit to try to preserve as
much as you can.
This was such a pleasure. 20 minutes go
by and it's not nearly enough to capture
the essence of of you yourself and of
salt, but h I think that we uh it's
definitely worth a try. So, thank you so
much for all the uh for all the
insights. Really appreciating it. Thank
you. Thank you so much.